je pense que samba qu'on peut pas entre
universités
et que l'on a un but mais celui où il
faisait toute la presse en fin d'études
et si on n'a pas le bac on ne peut pas
donc il faut le baccalauréat dans des
différentes 60 d'avoir certainement il
faut dimension il faut certaines choses
pour entrer dans les grandes écoles mais
à la base c'est un peu le pied à
l'étrier 150 fait rien à mon avis les
importantes puisque tu une ouverture
vers l'avenir
le délégation actuelle effet de contrôle
de telle manière que sans abarth
maintenant peut pas faire grand chose
oui il est un peu dévaluée dans le sens
d'avoir le bac il faut avoir le bac
d'une certaine façon avec une mention
sans mention sept ans on a le bac
enfin ça nous permet pas de faire des
grandes écoles donc il est d'évaluer ce
point de vue là bas sinon bon c'est
toucher toujours toujours un moyen pour
faire quelque chose n'est pas une fin en
soi
avec les bleus bacon n'est rien ou sans
le bac on est strictement rien c'est
vraiment beau sortir j'en suis sûr parce
que on rentre dans une entreprise on
aurait son bac mon le patron s'en
apercevoir s'en apercevra mais dans une
frappe attention mais si on arrive pour
se présenter sans son bac 7 sur qui vous
prendra pas en fait il ya le bac a le
bac b avec des accès et c'était même le
bac c'est qu'ils remportent enfin mieux
comme en plus de choses à faire
je pense que le mac représente la
capacité de l'élève de de retenir toute
une année de travail et que les
contrôles continus sont sa part sur une
partie du programme seulement et c'est
pas vraiment si c'est pas l'idéal vitro
par contre les
je pense que l'examen de fin d'année on
va c'est un travail de tous tes années
de synthèse de volonté énorme c'est
parce que le bac ça c'est pas si facile
que ça on n'en suis pas d'accord mc je
pense qu'il faut travailler jusqu'au
bout et travaillé toute l'année
régulièrement pour d'accord mais je
trouve que c'est un peu injuste de juger
un élève sur deux jours de cours alors
que en fait tu peux très bien voir
accident ce jour là
avoir été présents toute l'année ça
c'est la justice duels même si on
s'engage dans une voie pour des grandes
études on sait que c'est bouché déjà pas
en médecine architecture donc même en
faisant énormément d'étudiants pendant
en conséquence sept ans de sa vie pour
des études on sait très bien que ça va
être bouché alors nous demandent comment
faire
vous pensez de tout la même chose oui
quelque chose vous savez que c'est
bouché au départ et quand on branche
[Musique]